this question is what I call it's a it's
a question that stops you by
intimidation
it is not hard at all right it's not hot
it just looks it's meant to look like
are you serious like I don't even know
where to begin with this but once you
know where to begin
well that's all there is to it there's
nothing difficult about this question oh
ok so before we get anywhere near this
question I want to ask this question
will stay with will stay with three I
guess if I gave you let's see if I gave
you this question okay and said could
you solve for X right in this question
here okay most people who've got even a
basic understanding of what logs are
would be able to answer this question
and I'm going to take that understanding
because I think it's the it's the key to
unlocking this question okay so how
would we go about solving this like what
steps would you suggest that I do in
this question do you wanna give us a
okay so I'll just Chuck the X on the
left hand side because that's what I
want to solve for is okay no this is
exactly right this is exactly right and
the crucial thing to get is that there's
not in some senses there's not logic
because from here to here right this is
a definition this is actually what this
means right
they're just two different ways of
looking at the same reality okay it's a
little bit like me saying okay if you
see if you see an object like this right
and I've holed up on one side there's
heads okay
when I turn around say oh there's tails
on the other sides like what's the logic
between that and yeah it just there's no
logic it's just that a coin is supposed
to have heads on one side and tails on
the other by definition if heads on one
side tails me on the other okay now this
is actually just the definition of what
a log is okay it's a way to look at an
exponential equation that's that's what
this is okay and instead of making the
value of the whole thing like 3 to the
power of 1 upon instead of making that
the subject what's the subject in this
case is the power the power is the
subject
then what's the base racism power okay
now in this case three of the four
that's just 81 okay so you've got an
answer happy time now if I understand
that then this question is just three
lots of this question watch what should
sit for starters you notice about three
times sodden long awful mess three times
something is zero okay three times
something now this is an equation so I
can do to this equation anything I can
do to normal equations for instance I
could divide both sides by a number
right that's something you can do with
equations like if you saw this you
divide both sides by two and everything
would be fine okay so that's three out
the front it's just trying to it's just
like I said try to intimidate you right
it doesn't add anything I'm gonna divide
the left-hand side by three which means
I divide the right-hand side by three
okay just sit equated so on the
left-hand side what happens that three
out the front it just disappears it just
goes away
okay so I get this log base three of
this awful mess log base 3 X and that's
still equal to zero do you care with
that all right now what you've got here
is exactly what I had here just with the
zero on the right hand side right so if
I just you can see I have log base three
of something I'll call back leg like
exit y is equal to zero right so
therefore the next line is three to the
power 0 should be up there
what's 32 PI zero again it's just one in
fact anything to the power 0 it's just
one okay
so therefore what's up in here this
thing here will be one right log base
three of log base 3 of 3 x equals 3 to
the 0 do you see what I've done there
okay so I'm trying to complain I've
unpacked this log 3 and this
I have become this three of the zero see
what I've done it just like this three
and this is your pick a mystery in this
zero okay morning okay now I evaluate as
you just told me a bitter to go through
the power 0 is 1 so 1 on the right hand
side log 3 X so now what I do with this
well I just I just keep on peeling off
layers of the onion right so I've got
two more locks to go log base 3 of
something equals 1 that means that
there's something that's just what it is
that it should be equal to yeah 3 ^ 1
which of course is 3 okay 3 & 5 1 you
see that this 3 to the 1 comes from this
3 to the power of 1 see that so now I've
just got one more step to go 3 about
what as we've just noticed is just 3 so
now I can say what's left
it's 3 to the x sorry 3 X which is equal
to you could winning this 3 to power
this which i think is 27 right so 3x
equals 27
so now I divide both sides by 3 so this
is not a fun question it's a long
question it takes me a while to unpack
everything here but every step I was
actually more or less doing the same
thing each time this leap I was doing
this it's just that because of they be
so much stuff in there it was harder to
see